In the add co-instructors
and teaching assistants video,
we saw how to add members
to our workspace one by one.
But what if we want to add a large number
of individuals to our space at once?
There are several ways to add multiple
members to your workspace at once.
And in this video
we'll go through the sharing link option.
Please check out the
rscloud package video
if you're interested in learning
how to add multiple members via
the RStudio Cloud API.
To add multiple individuals
to our workspace
let's click on the members button
at the top of our workspace
and then click on options
to open the access menu. From here
let's invite multiple individuals
using the sharing link.
This method will give us a link
that we can distribute via email
or on a course web page,
allowing all of our learners to access the
workspace on RStudio Cloud.
For the initial role
we'll choose contributors,
and then take a look at the permissions
at the bottom of the page.
We can choose what contributors
are allowed to do within the workspace
by selecting or de-selecting
the options presented.
Once we've made our selections
we can click on copy
sharing link and distribute it as needed.
Once all of our learners
have joined the shared workspace
we can disable the existing link
by resetting the sharing link
or by setting our workspace
to invitation required,
which will mean new learners
to the workspace will have to be added via
the add member button from within
the member section of our workspace.